well i'm delighted to share with you know
that this is really a historic event for us
I'm Vera Ingrid grant and i am the executive director
of the W.E.B. Du Bois Institute
at Harvard university
the project
is like nothing else i've seen
and uh i am what you call a novice scholar
in this field but i've been studying this for
over fifteen years myself
the program actually began
what we call the image of the black in western
art
with Dominic danielle she wanted to bring
in some influences from Euroup specifically
images of blacks
in european paintings sculpture art and
architecture
that she felt represented people of color
in a much more positive way
she published seven volumes and then went
from pre Egyptian time all the way up
world war one
this one century that was missing
and that was the eighteenth century that dealt
with the expansion of slavery
and the further development of colonialism
in nineteen uh ninety four
the mineola foundation
decided to transfer the project
to harvard university under the Du Bois institute
with Henry louis Gates
to go back
through time and to take  these images
out and put them in the context of European
art thats been study for centuries and look
at how they were interactions with people
from Africa all throughout that history
i think this is something new that many
people don't know about them haven't shared
so this is important work that i think that
we want to share with everyone today
white black hispanic asian and all of the people
that make up united states and beyond
who tragedy people who have experienced
wonderful things in their lives
i think will be enriched by understanding
these images and stories behind them